JESSE, DANA, >> Emily: .
"THE FIVE" ."
SO IT TURNS OUT THAT THE WRITERS
HAVE INITIALLY INCLUDED THE FACT
THAT THEY COULDN'T RECALL THE
ALLEGED INCIDENT OF THAT HUGE
STORY.
BUT THE TIMES TOOK IT OUT OF
THEIR OWN ARTICLE.
>> I THINK WHAT HAPPENED
ACTUALLY WAS THAT WE HAD HER
NAME.
AND YOU KNOW, "THE TIMES"
DOESN'T USUALLY INCLUDE IT.
IN REMOVING HER NAME, THEY
REMOVED THE OTHER REFERENCE TO
THE FACT THAT SHE DIDN'T
REMEMBER.
IT WAS SORT OF EDITING DONE IN A
HASTE.
>> Greg: SO THIS HUMONGOUS
DETAIL DISAPPEARED IN THE HASTE
OF THE EDITING PROCESS.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THAT WE LEFT
OUT THE FACT THAT THE TITANIC
SANK.
THIS WAS NO ERROR.
THIS WAS A BUSINESS DECISION.
WHEN THE VICTIM RENOUNCED HER
OWN VICTIMHOOD, THEY RENOUNCED
IT.
THEY SUGGESTED SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
HOW DO THEY STILL HAVE JOBS?
AND WHAT ABOUT HER ALLIES WHO
THREATENED TO SUE ONE WITNESS?
SHE DIDN'T BACK UP HER STORY.
THAT'S PRETTY HUGE TOO.
SOMEHOW THAT GOT IGNORED TOO.
BUT THIS IS THE MEDIA.
THE ONLY REASON THAT THIS HASN'T
HAPPENED TO YOU, VIEWER, IS THAT
THEY DON'T CONSIDER YOU
IMPORTANT ENOUGH.
SOONER OR LATER, THEY WILL
REPORT REPUBLICANS, FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES OF REPUBLICANS.
THEY WORK BACKWARDS, ERASING ANY
FACTS THAT HINDER THEIR REVERSE
ENGINEERING.
AND SO, KAVANAUGH.
IN TIME, THOUGH DO THIS TO YOU
IF YOU EVER MAKE THEIR RADAR,
BECAUSE THE INSTITUTIONAL MEDIA
IS IN A PANIC.
IT'S ALL SELF-INFLICTED.
EMILY, IT'S INTERESTING.
THE REPORTERS GENTLY THROUGH THE
EDITORS UNDER THE BUS.
AND THEN WHEN THEY TALKED ABOUT
THE VICTIM NOT COOPERATING, THEY
WERE LIKE, OH, SHE'S PROBABLY
DRUNK.
>> Emily: YOU KNOW ONCE A WHAT I
>> Emily: YOU KNOW ONCE A WHAT M
SICK OF?
I'M SICK OF BEING TAKEN FOR AN
IDIOT.
IT'S LIKE, OH, YOU WON'T KNOW.
YOU WON'T CARE.
SO WHY DON'T YOU JUST TAKE WHAT
I GIVE YOU AND DIGEST IT?
IN THE PROCESS OF DEMOCRACY
DYING IN DARKNESS.
I REALLY HATE THIS HYPOCRISY
COMING OUT OF THE LEFT, WHERE
ONCE AGAIN, THEY ARE TELLING
SOMEONE, "OH HERE HONEY.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT OH, YOUR STRUGGLES WITH
MOONSHINE ARE THE REASONS WHY
YOU CAN'T REMEMBER."
THIS CREATED SUCH A
RIPPLE EFFECT IN TERMS OF SHAM
JOURNALISM.
JUST LAST MONTH, IT WAS
SOLIDIFIED THAT A NOW PROFESSOR,
BUT ONE OF KAVANAUGH'S
CLASSMATES SUED
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" OVER THE
ARTICLE OF.
THEIR INSINUATIONS, OR ACTUALLY
THERE DECLARATIONS THAT HE
PROVIDED THE DRUGS THAT HE
OVERDOSED OVER.
THEY LITERALLY DEFAMED HIM MORE.
AND NOW, THEIR STORY, BY THE WAY
HE DOES NOT EVEN MENTION THE
DEATH OF DAVID KENNEDY AND THE
O.D. IN 1984.
THEY BASICALLY DUG A HOLE EVEN
DEEPER.
>> Greg: IN AN EFFORT TO GET
TWEETED BY DONALD TRUMP, I'M
GOING TO SAY TO YOU THAT
JOURNALISM IS DEAD AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" KILLED IT.
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAH,
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHW
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHE
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHN
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHI
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHH
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHA
>> Jesse: >> Juan: YEAHD
YOU SAY THAT,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS HIGHLY
PROFITABLE THESE DAYS.
>> Greg: YEAH, I MEAN, THEY
ARE LYING TO AMERICA.
IMAGINE IF HILLARY SAID THAT.
HARVEY WEINSTEIN WOULD BE HAPPY,
BECAUSE THAT STORY WHEN IT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> Juan: WELCOME I THINK
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" MADE A BIG
MISTAKE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN INSIGHT
INTO LEFT-WING POLITICS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN MY MIND, THIS WAS NOT A
COORDINATED ASSAULT, SORT OF BY
AN ALL-POWERFUL LIBERAL MEDIA
INSTITUTION.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I WOULD SAY, IF
THAT WAS THE CASE, IF THEY WERE
UP AT INSTINCTS, I THINK THEY
WOULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
HIM, BUT THEY NEVER SAID
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THEY SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
KAVANAUGH.
AND I THINK THE SECOND THING.
NO, I THINK THAT THE IDEA WAS,
REMEMBER, THEY DID NOT ALLOW HIM
A LEGITIMATE SHOT AT HAVING NOT
ONLY A BOAT, BUT A SIMPLE
HEARING.
SO I THINK THAT IF YOU WERE
SAYING, OH, YEAH, THEY COULD
ATTACK ANYONE, THEY DID NOT.
I THINK THE REAL ISSUE IS, ONE,
THE FBI AGAIN, LACK OF
INVESTIGATION.
HEY, YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING.
THERE WAS A PIECE IN THE PAPERS
TODAY --
>> Jesse: DONE WHAT?
>> Juan: THEY SHOULD HAVE
INVESTIGATED.
>> Jesse: DONE WHAT?
>> Juan: I WAS JUST ABOUT TO
TELL YOU.
HE WROTE THAT HE WAS AT YALE AT
THAT TIME.
HE CONTACTED THE FBI.
25 OTHER PEOPLE.
NOBODY EVER GOT A RESPONSE
VARIED AND NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE
SAYING, "I THINK, HARRIS DID
THIS.
IT'S NECESSARY TO LOOK AT THE
CONSTRAINTS PUT ON THE FBI.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T
INVESTIGATE SOMETHING WHERE
NOBODY SAW ANYTHING HAPPENED.
YOU'RE SAYING 25 WELL-CONNECTED
YALE GRADUATES CAN'T GET THE
WORD OUT IN WASHINGTON, D.C., ?
COME ON, JUAN.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, JUAN.
I WOULD LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
MYSELF FOR CORRECTLY PREDICTING
YESTERDAY THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PURPOSELY
LET THIS SLIDE, BECAUSE THIS WAS
NOT A MISTAKE.
THIS WAS DONE INTENTIONALLY.
AND TODAY, WE KNOW IT WAS DONE
INTENTIONALLY BY THE EDITORS WHO
TOOK IT OUT.
SO IF YOU ARE A "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITOR, HERE'S YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS.
ANTI-SEMITIC CARTOONS.
THAT STAYS IN.
YOU GOT TO EDIT THAT OUT.
THE MONOLOGUE ABOUT THIS WOMAN
WHO WAS PRESSURED AND THREATENED
TO LIVE TO THE FBI AND SAY THAT
SOMETHING HAPPENED THAT SHE
DIDN'T BELIEVE HAPPENED, THE GUY
THAT IS SAYING THAT HE DIDN'T
WITNESS THIS MISCONDUCT, HE
HEARD ABOUT MISCONDUCT, HE
WORKED FOR BILL CLINTON, AND YOU
KNOW WHO WAS ON THE OPPOSING
SIDE OF THAT BATTLE?
BRETT KAVANAUGH DURING THE
IMPEACHMENT BATTLE, BECAUSE WE
TELL MIKE HE WAS ON HIS TEAM.
THAT WAS ALSO LEFT OUT OF THIS
WHOLE THING.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT SAVED
HIM BACK THEN.
AND THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE
UPSET ABOUT KAVANAUGH, I MEAN,
YEAH.
THIS IS UPSETTING TO HIM AND HIS
FAMILY.
THEY DO THIS TO DONALD TRUMP
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS LEFT OUT
ABOUT THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
STORY.
BRENNAN, KLAPPER, McCABE.
NOW THEY ARE STILL LOOKING THE
OTHER WAY.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE, I CAN
NEVER LOOK AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THE SAME
WAY AGAIN.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
YOU HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
YOU ARE AN AMERICAN.
>> Greg: THIS STORY IS HUGE.
>> Dana: YET, BUT IT ALSO
SHOWS WHAT SHE SAID A YEAR AGO
AT THE SAME TIME, WHERE SHE IS
LIKE, "OH WAIT.
ACTUALLY NO."
WHEN JUAN SAID THAT THIS WAS NOT
AN INSIGHT INTO IT, I DISAGREE,
BECAUSE AS SOON AS THAT STORY
POSTED, YOU HAD SEVERAL
DEMOCRATIC 2020 CANDIDATES
SAYING THAT HE MUST BE IMPEACHE
IMPEACHED.
THEY CAN'T WAIT FOR HALF A
SECOND.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
JUDGMENT.
A RUSH OF JUDGMENT.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW RASH
THAT IS.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
ABOUT THIS WHOLE THING IS IN
2004 AND FIVE, ZERO FOUR, '05.
IN ZERO FIVE, I WAS ONE OF THE
SPOKESPEOPLE FOR IT.
IT WAS A VERY CONTROVERSIAL
NOMINATION.
THIS WAS NEVER BROUGHT UP.
NOT ONCE.
WHAT THEY WENT AFTER HIM FOR IN
2005 WAS TORTURE AND WHETHER HE
HAD WRITTEN A MEMO ALONG THE WAY
THAT ENCOURAGED THE PRESIDENT TO
SAY, "YES.
OKAY.
YOU CAN SIGN OFF ON TORTURE."
I DO THINK THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
SHOULD SUE.
I THINK HE WOULD WIN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE WORTHWHILE.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> Greg: WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS LATER IN THE
SHOW, DANA.
>> Emily: IT'S RIGHT HERE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: I'M JUST TEASING,
DANA.
>> Emily: I'M SO CONFUSED.